[Música]
Después de tres años de cierre total de
sus fronteras Colombia y Venezuela
dieron un paso más en su
restablecimiento de relaciones
comerciales con la apertura de pasos
fronterizos hay expectativa por el
potencial de intercambio comercial entre
ambos países que podría llegar a 10.000
millones de dólares anuales
hoy se cumplen ocho años de la
desaparición de los 43 estudiantes de
Ayotzinapa en Iguala en el estado
mexicano de Guerrero la comisión de la
verdad calificó la masacre de crimen de
estado cerca de 60 personas han sido
detenidas en relación con los hechos con
marchas en Ciudad de México exigieron a
las autoridades el esclarecimiento de lo
ocurrido
y con éxito las ondas de la NASA impactó
en el asteroide dimorfos pronto los
científicos sabrán si dar consiguió su
objetivo de desviar la trayectoria del
asteroide se trata del primer ensayo de
este tipo de estrategia para defender
nuestro planeta de un cuerpo Celeste que
resulte peligroso para la tierra
Bienvenidos a este informativo dedicado
a las principales noticias del
continente americano abrimos esta
emisión con la reapertura de la frontera
entre Colombia y Venezuela luego de
siete años de tensiones diplomáticas los
países vecinos reabrieron su zona
fronteriza con el paso de dos camiones
de carga a través del puente
internacional Simón Bolívar el cual
representó el regreso de la relación
comercial binacional
una Reconciliación entre hermanos eso
simbolizó el paso de dos camiones de
carga por el puente internacional Simón
Bolívar que retomaron el paso comercial
transfronterizo tras siete años de
cierre parcial y tres de bloqueo total
un acto que el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro celebró
necesariamente las dos economías tienen
que integrarse estamos hablando de una
zona
especial
entre el táchira y norte de Santander
para que sea plataforma de la
industrialización
para que
la calidad de vida sea general y también
su homólogo venezolano Nicolás Maduro en
lo que definió como un día histórico
estamos retomando relaciones y dando
pasos firmes para avanzar en la apertura
total y absoluta de la frontera entre
pueblos hermanos Colombia y Venezuela es
un día histórico y trascendental los
vehículos de carga podrán transitar
entre las 19 horas y las 6 de la mañana
y los peatones entre las 6 de la mañana
y las 18 horas con un flujo estimado de
30.000 personas diarias por ahora esto
Solo aplicará a dos de los ocho puentes
fronterizos El Simón Bolívar y el
Francisco de Paula Santander y aún no se
sabe cuándo podrán transitar vehículos
particulares con la reapertura Se
esperan mil millones de dólares anuales
de flujo económico cifra aún muy lejana
de los 2.400 millones de dólares en 2014
y los 7000 en 2008 los habitantes de
ambas partes de la frontera de 2.200
kilómetros tienen esperanza
de la gente que se anima a pasarse por
el río por la necesidad e ir a Colombia
a conseguir lo que no hay acá en
Venezuela pues es muy bueno para los dos
países y en muchos sacrificio que
tenemos que pasar esperar a hacer cosas
mojanos de todo ves con la reapertura
comercial además de los camiones se han
visto miles de personas cruzando ahora
el siguiente reto es analizar temas de
seguridad y de salud en la zona mientras
en Colombia la derecha Aún se opone a
este cambio por las acusaciones de
violaciones de Derechos Humanos que
pesan sobre el chavismo más tarde en el
día del presidente venezolano Nicolás
Maduro agradeció a su homólogo
colombiano la reapertura de esta
frontera
le envió al presidente Gustavo Petro y
el agradecimiento de más de 30 millones
de venezolanos y venezolanas
por este paso
inmenso que hemos dado
para restituir
las relaciones de hermandad de Unión de
cooperación de complementariedad
entre nuestros pueblos que es lo más
importante entre tanto la oposición al
gobierno de Gustavo Petro organizó
marchas en contra del Ejecutivo en toda
Colombia las más numerosas tuvieron
lugar en Bogotá Cali y Medellín miles de
personas marcharon en protesta contra
los proyectos de reformas tributaria y
laboral y además de la salud el alza a
los precios de la gasolina y la invasión
de tierras según informaron los
organizadores que anunciaron una nueva
jornada de movilización para el 24 de
octubre
y nos vamos a este Ecuador para hablar
con nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega
sobre el caso María Belén Bernal quien
fue encontrada sin vida en un cerro
cercano de la escuela superior de
policía en el norte de Quito presidente
Guillermo lasso aseguró que se trabajará
en la erradicación de la violencia de
género y hoy se llevó a cabo el cierre
simbólico del edificio donde Se presume
que fue cometido el feminicidio lasso
ratificó además la búsqueda de Germán
Cáceres principal sospechoso
precisamente nuestro corresponsal
Gustavo Ortega no se ampliaba
anteriormente los anuncios del
presidente
Hola qué tal Rodrigo bueno en las
declaraciones fueron realizadas el día
de hoy por parte del presidente de la
república y específicamente lo hizo en
medio de un recorrido por la escuela
superior de la publicidad en principio
se posicionó el día de hoy al nuevo
ministro de interior y Justicia teniente
coronel Juan Zapata Juan Zapata se era
se mantenía en un servicio pasivo era un
oficial Se mantenían servicio pasivo de
la policía debería ejecutando acciones
como director de Durante los últimos 16
meses de el principal cuerpo de atención
de emergencias el eq911 que es un
principal centro de atenciones de
emergencia de este país se posicionó el
día de hoy y luego de ello partieron a
la escuela superior de la policía donde
el presidente de la república Guillermo
lazo dio algunos anuncios en principio
él da ocho días de plazo para que la
policía
de con información y la captura de
Germán en Cáceres principal sospechoso
por el femicidio de María Belén otro los
anuncios que dio también Es sobre el
proceso de asesoría que ahora recibe por
parte de oro mujeres para poder cambiar
así la estructura de funcionamiento
formativo de la Policía Nacional nos
vamos ahora hasta Brasil en concreto a
la ciudad de Sao Paulo allí tuvo lugar
un acto de campaña del candidato del
partido de los trabajadores y ex
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el
favorito en las encuestas pidió el voto
para poner fin a lo que denominó como la
guerra instalada en el país desde la
llegada al gobierno de su rival
electoral el actual presidente Yair
bolsonaro en las encuestas más recientes
Lula aparece con un 48% de intención de
Voto un punto más que la semana pasada
frente al 31% de bolsonaro la primera
vuelta de las elecciones tendrá lugar
este próximo domingo 2 de octubre
escuchamos a Lula da Silva
una elección que puede poner fin a la
guerra instalada en este país desde la
llegada al poder del actual presidente
basta de tanto odio de tanta destrucción
de tantas mentiras de tanto sufrimiento
y de tantas muertes
vamos el día 2 de octubre a reconstruir
el país que soñamos
el 26 de septiembre se cumplieron ocho
años de la desaparición de los 43
estudiantes de la Escuela Normal de
Ayotzinapa la masacre ha sido calificada
de crimen de estado por la comisión de
la verdad que Investiga los hechos
ocurridos en 2014 en igual a en el
Estado de Guerrero cerca de 60 personas
han sido detenidas por su presunta
vinculación con la matanza entre las
cuales miembros de la fuerza pública en
la capital Ciudad de México tuvo lugar
una marcha multitudinaria para exigir
verdad y Justicia Desde allí se
pronunció el abogado las familias de los
desaparecidos
presentó un informe el mes de agosto
sin embargo luego de lo cual hay señales
que van en dirección contraria a
se ha desistido de 16 órdenes de
aprehensión contra militares de cinco
funcionarios en el Estado de Guerrero y
buena parte de la comunidad científica
mundial estaba en vilo ante la misión de
una nave de la Nasa que se estrelló alta
velocidad contra un asteroide con el
objetivo de desviar su trayectoria la
Sonda Dart impactó de manera controlada
a 6,4 kilómetros por segundo contra la
superficie del asteroide dimorfos a unos
11 millones de kilómetros de la tierra
si bien el impacto fue exitoso pasarán
días o incluso semanas para que los
científicos determinan si darte logró
alterar la órbita del asteroide
vamos a ver cuando la información se
descargue pronto en los próximos días y
en los próximos dos meses tendremos más
información que tendrá el equipo de
investigación sobre Qué cambios reales
logramos Porque esa era nuestra segunda
meta la primera era golpear el asteroide
que ya hemos hecho pero la segunda es
realmente medir ese cambio caracterizar
Cuánta eyección generamos hasta aquí
este repaso informativo llegan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]